Personnellement,
je déteste les mecs musclés.
Voilà, ça m'énerve, c'est tout.
C'est pas du tout de la jalousie. Faux !
OK, OK, c'est de la jalousie.
En fait, ce qui m'énerve,
c'est que les mecs musclés,
dans certaines situations, ils nous créent des complexes,
tu vois, chez nous, les mecs pas très musclés.
'Tain, il fait chaud, là !
>> Ah, j'avoue, putain !
Wow ! Wow ! [rires]
Norman ?
>> Non, j'ai pas chaud, en fait.
Les mecs musclés, ils mettent pas
les mêmes genres de T-shirts que nous.
Tu vois, eux, ils mettent des T-shirts faits
pour qu'on voit le plus possible leur musculature.
Le mec, même son téton est moulé.
Des fois, ils mettent carrément des T-shirts filés,
pour qu'on voit à travers.
À la limite, autant rien
mettre du tout, quoi !
Ce genre de T-shirts, tu peux les mettre
seulement si t'es musclé.
Salut ! Est-ce que tu veux
sortir avec moi ?
[bip]
Dommage !
On sait tous pourquoi
les mecs musclés se musclent.
Ça veut dire, voilà, on n'est pas bête, on sait que,
voilà, c'est toujours pour la même raison.
En, pourquoi tu as commencé la muscu ?
Qu'est-ce qui t'a motivé ?
Pour mon bien-être,
pour mon équilibre.
Juste ton équilibre ?
>> Oui, juste mon équilibre. T'as pas des capotes ?
Heureusement que toutes les filles
sont pas comme ça
et qu'il y en a certaines quand même
qui aiment bien les mecs pas forcément musclés.
Mais moi, j'aime pas les torses trop musclés, tu vois.
Je préfère les torses normaux, sans muscle.
Ah, genre quand y'a pas de muscle, tu préfères.
>> Ouais.
>> Ah ben ça me rassure,
parce que c'est vrai que moi, bon...
Excusez-moi, Mademoiselle, je peux
vous prendre votre crème solaire ?
Mais bien sûr.
>> Merci.
>> C'est pour mettre sur vos —?
>> Oui, c'est ça.
Attends, attends, parce que
à la base, on sortait ensemble.
Bon j'avoue, c'est vrai que
quand on est pas forcément musclé,
des fois, on est un peu jaloux, tu vois ?
Du coup, on trouve des excuses.
Non mais ça va, là, il contracte.
C'est facile, moi si je contracte, c'est pareil, c'est—
Eh ben vas-y, contracte !
>> Non mais je vais pas contracter
maintenant, c'est pas—
Ben si, vas-y !
>> OK, regarde là, je contracte.
Ah non, là, tu contractes pas.
>> Si, je contracte.
>> Ben non.
Bon j'ai pas envie de contracter, c'est tout !
J'ai pas envie de contracter aujourd'hui.
Après, je comprends, c'est vrai
qu'un torse musclé, c'est joli à regarder.
Un mec, ça peut trouver
les muscles d'un autre mec beaux, tu vois ?
[sifflements] En tout cas, pas mal les pecs, hein !
>> Merci.
Après, il faut quand même
qu'il y ait des limites.
'Tain, il était bien musclé,
quand même, ce mec.
Ah, il était vraiment, vraiment
musclé, quand même, wow !
Pourquoi tu me regardes comme ça ?
C'est vrai que nous, les mecs pas musclés,
comme on est assez jaloux des mecs musclés,
on aime bien dire
ce genre de phrase :
Oui mais c'est de la gonflette.
Ces mecs-là, on sait tous que, voilà,
c'est bien beau, ils ont des muscles,
mais ils ont aucune force.
Par exemple, c'est de la gonflette.
Le mec, il a pas de force, c'est clair.
C'est vrai que moi, dès que l'été arrive, j'ai toujours envie
d'être un peu musclé sur la plage, tu vois ?
Sauf que c'est trop tard.
Normal, c'est trop tard, là.
>> 10. Ah, j'ai pris, là.
J'ai pris un peu.
>> Ouais, t'as pris un coup de soleil.
Oui, ben j'ai pris.
Le pire, tu vois, ce qui m'énerve
vraiment le plus, je crois,
c'est les mecs qui sont musclés,
mais sans rien faire.
Alors, eux, ils font pas de muscu,
c'est leur corps.
Genre les mecs, ils sont nés,
ils étaient déjà un bébé musclé.
Ça, c'est naturel ?
>> Ouais.
>> D'accord.
OK.
>> Et toi, c'est naturel aussi ?
Ah non, moi, ça fait deux ans que je fais de la muscu, là.
>> Ah.
Moi, je serai jamais musclé dans ma vie,
je pense, parce que, voilà,
j'ai pas la motive de faire de la muscu, c'est trop long
et puis ça me correspond pas.
Tu vois, c'est pas ma personnalité,
moi, je suis un mec pas musclé
et je suis bien comme ça. Tu vois,
j'assume pleinement mon corps.
OK.
Passe la balle.
>> T'es sérieux, là ?
Passe la balle !
Hé, on peut jouer au foot, s'il te plaît ?
C'est la coupe du monde.
Au fait, ma page Facebook
"Norman fait des vidéos"
vient de dépasser
les 3 millions de j'aime,
c'est gigantesque, merci à tous,
ça fait trop plaisir.
Donc ça, c'est les confettis, ça.
Tchao !
[♪ musique ♪]
C'est quoi la marque
de ton shampooing ?
Alors, ça s'appelle White Spirit.
Pourquoi tu ne te présentes pas
aux élections présidentielles ?
Parce que si j'étais président
de la république, tu vois...
Mon spectacle
"Norman sur scène"
commence à partir de septembre,
en tournée dans toute la galaxie
et aussi à Chalon sur Seine.
Pour venir me voir, cliquez sur le lien dans la description.